will be in conversation with our guest
catherine paige harden a psychologist
and behavioral geneticist she's
professor of psychology at the
university of texas in austin where
she's also leader of the developmental
behavior genetics lab and the
co-director of the very cool sounding
texas twin project her new book here we
go is the genetic lottery why dna
matters for social equality now our
event tonight is going to run for about
an hour half of that will be me and half
of that will be you asking questions so
just look out for the box at the bottom
of your screen and ask away
um paige i want to start where the book
starts which is with children um and
maybe with your children what did having
kids teach you that working as a
genetics researcher didn't
i think in many ways it wasn't about
teaching me something different but just
really driving
home the forces uh of lessons that you
can hear about in the abstract but the
felt reality of them isn't really real
until you have kids
and that lesson is that children are
different from one another and even
children within the same family
are different from one another so often
when we think about genetics we're
thinking about
similarity between parents and children
and that's true but thinking about
genetics just in terms of similarity
allies the fact that there is so much
variation within families
my children are
different from one another and their
personality and their temperament in
their speech and language development in
how they do in school
i think most parents see those
differences play out in their lives as a
geneticist i just had tools i think
ready to understand those differences
and thinking about how they fit with a
larger pattern of what we see in the
population
children are not born exactly the same
and why did you want to write this book
because i should say that every time
i've seen this book mentioned it has
been with a kind of
catherine page hardin has stepped into
the bear cage you know like she's done
work she's put her hand into this
hornet's nest so
with that we'll talk a bit about why you
know this subject is very controversial
later but but what was the thing that
you wanted to say what do you think
needs saying on this subject
i think there's two things that need
saying
one is that the dna revolution is here
that science is accelerating by leaps
and bounds
and i think that that
advance of technology is gonna really
influence people's lives
sort of regardless of what they do um
you know the the dna revolution is here
to say so i think it's important for
people and to understand
what are scientists doing with that
information how do we link genetics not
just to things like height or disease
but to things like
intelligence or personality or how far
children go in school
and so part of the goal in writing this
book was to explain the science
and clear up a lot of myths and
misunderstandings around the science
and then my second goal in writing the
book is so often
that research of linking genetics to
differences between people that we care
about
um
is told in terms of one story that it
naturalizes inequality that genetics is
sort of an enemy of equality and i
personally don't see it that way i i am
approaching this topic not just as a
scientist but as someone who
is personally morally and politically
committed to
egalitarianism to political equality
between people
um and there didn't really seem to be
any space in the conversation around
genetics that had paid attention to that
how can we think about equality in a
world of difference
in particular in genetic difference and
so i thought it was important to
describe
how i as someone who's committed to
equality and but also who spend a lot of
time
time thinking about the science and its
limitations think of these things going
together
so let's talk about the two you know
troublesome intellectual traditions
first of all the tradition of eugenics
so that's a phrase
coined by francis galton a victorian
scientist at the end of the 19th
beginning of the 20th century um you
know who also came up the idea of nature
versus nurture this idea that we need to
try and separate out what things are
caused by environment and what things
buy um by inheritance
he actually wrote a very weird novella
about you know um a eugenic paradise as
he saw it where people were kind of
given breeding licenses essentially and
and as we know those ideas were taken up
in u.s states where some people who
would be mentally disabled were
sterilized and then later by the nazis
so
how
how much of that was in your mind when
you're writing the book that you need to
be writing to counter to a particular
tradition that's been about classifying
people as feeble-minded or whatever else
it might be
i mean that tradition loomed really
large in my mind and writing the book
but i think more generally in doing the
science a big part of responsible
science communication
isn't just talking about what is the
science saying but also what is the
science not saying not just how should
it be used but how should it not be used
and particularly
when we're talking about genetics in
relation to education or intelligence
that history to anyone who's even had
like a you know a passing knowledge of
the early 20th century in the uk and
germany in the us
immediately is aware of
the potential dangers is this knowledge
going to be misused are we going to
animate or reanimate these ugly ideas
about inferiority and superiority
and i think in particularly in an
american context where
um the reproductive rights debate more
generally is so contentious and
acrimonious um there's also
that history um when we're talking about
the history of eugenics in the us we're
talking about involuntary sterilization
we're talking about women being deprived
of very basic reproductive rights
um so
thinking about that history
was
um
important both in terms of trying to
um
articulate why that work is not
necessary why the research is not
necessarily going to lead to these
pernicious ends but also challenging me
to think about what is it for if it's
not going to be co-opted by the most
pernicious voices if we're not thinking
about um
connecting genes to intelligence for the
purposes of this dystopian control of
people's reproduction
what can we use it for what is the good
of it so um thinking about the lessons
of the past and how we can carry those
forward um is a theme that runs
throughout the entire book i think
did it make you feel more
that you had to be humble about the
limits of science because i think one of
the things that comes across most
strongly when you read about eugenics in
the early 20th century is how incredibly
intellectually respectable it was you
know this wasn't a couple of fringe
scientists you know they were naming a
department uh at king's college and they
had kind of the eugene the golden chair
of eugenics you know the eugenics
department the eugenics review was a
magazine you know this was and this
wasn't as we would now i think
associated with it with the right this
was the fabian society founders were
eugenesis you know this was seen as a
kind paternal thing to to do to help the
underclass as they would have been seen
then and and that's the story about
being humble in the face of what what
scientists can
convince themselves are good ideas right
i think that they can convince
themselves of their good ideas but i
think they can also convince themselves
that being
um
really good at one thing generalizes to
expertise in a lot of domains you know i
think galton is a great example of that
he was
a brilliant mind
in some areas when we think about his
illustrations of the normal distribution
and how it could arise from a series of
binary events that was a real insight
that kind of
insight however valuable
um doesn't necessarily generalize to
then making sweeping social
recommendations that infringe on
the rights of others so the lesson for
me in that is not just being humble
about the limits of your science but
also being
humble about how you know expertise in
one domain
i think often when people particularly
men are good in one domain people other
people sort of rush in to make them
authorities on many things um and i
think there's a lesson in the dangers of
that too here
oh i think that's yeah i mean i'm
fascinated by the idea of the kind of
who gets to be a public intellectual and
the idea that because you are a
brilliant scientist suddenly people
think that you know how best to organize
a political system and you think what
you know why would this it's not like
artists are also brilliant plumbers like
i just don't know why you would make
those assumptions but you you did try
and read quite widely outside your
discipline there's a lot of john rules
for example in the book so what else
were you reading to try and complement
your expertise in genetics
so i was reading a lot of political
philosophy and philosophy of science and
that work was supported by
actually a really interesting grant from
the john templeton foundation that
brought together half of the fundies
were behavioral scientists or genetic
scientists and the other half of the
fundies were
philosophers of science or scientists
whose work touched on
distributive or retributive justice
in some way and there's actually so few
opportunities as a scientist to spend
time
not just reading but being in
conversation writing papers with
presenting your work to
people in the humanities who have
training around the philosophy of
science and these disciplines so that
experience was really um
foundational to writing the book
so often of the conversations around
genetics are not really around genetics
they're around fairness they're around
equality they're around justice
and i didn't want to just say
well this is what the science does and
here are my opinions on these other
issues i wanted to say
well there's a whole philosophical
literature that considers what do we do
with luck
when we in our conversations of equality
and then there's a whole new emerging
genetic science about how
the luck of the genetic draw affects our
lives how can we be more deliberate
about linking these two areas of
scholarship to one another
and rolls was a great fit for that
because one of his you know most
enduring contributions to the
philosophical literature
is this idea of the veil of ignorance
you know if you had no idea
what your position was going to be
either in the outcome of the social
lottery or what he called the natural
lottery how would you want society
arranged and so that's what i'm
encouraging many of the readers to think
about if we take the science of genetics
seriously and then you also consider
what type of social structures if you
didn't know what your genotype was going
to be or you didn't know what your kid's
genotype was going to be
how might how might that give you new
imaginings about what you consider a
good society those are the questions i'm
inviting the readers to consider
i was interested when i got to reading
the book about how much more radical it
was than i thought because i was fully
prepared to accept the idea that
intelligence was partly heritable and
therefore you know that being
intelligent isn't something you can
boast about as if it's a personal
achievement because it is luck of the
draw but there's also stuff in there
about the idea that
grit you know that conscientiousness
that um
uh lack of risk taking you know all of
these things that are also correlated
with success in life educational
attainment as it's currently set up
those might also be partly heritable and
again therefore you can't really take
credit for being hard-working or
whatever it might be that that i think
people will find incredibly challenging
i think it's really challenging because
we're used to being able
we're used to to
to the illusion that we're going to be
able to kind of neatly carve up our
lives into
this part was luck
and this is the part that i can take
credit for
and the thing about genetics
and i think this is part of why it
causes so much controversy is that it
really confounds those intuitions
because
if we're tracing out
genetic influences on personality for
instance
your genes are something that you can't
take
credit for like in terms of i you know
i'm very proud that i have this dna
sequence right that's like being very
proud that i have green eyes
um
but if those genes shape our biology in
such a way that we are
more likely to be persistent or are more
likely to delay gratification
or
um are less likely to have addiction
problems or adhd then that line between
agency and credit and desert what we
deserve
in luck
and you know there but for the grace of
god go i starts to get
muddled to the point of disappearing
right um
so my point in the book is not that no
one can take credit for anything
in their lives i think it'd be kind of
impossible
as a human to go through our life
without
trying to think about this is the part
i'm responsible for this is what i need
to try harder on this is this is the
thing that i can feel proud of
accomplishing
um
but
it does
suggest that any efforts to arrange a
social order
to meet out rewards according to what
people deserve it's going to it's going
to rapidly run up into a point of kind
of near impossibility from an empirical
standpoint you know this is again a
rosian idea where he says none of the
precepts of justice
tend towards
dessert right tend towards rewarding
dessert because it's impossible at a
certain point so if we're going to give
up on the idea of separating things into
what people deserve versus don't deserve
then what we do then then how do we go
about thinking about about equality and
fairness and that's a really difficult
you know question that i'm not giving a
comprehensive answer to the book i'm
more
bringing in the results of genetics to
encourage people to think about those
really difficult questions
yeah there's a very good example i think
where you're talking about how you would
design a school curriculum and trying to
make the decision between do you tilt it
towards something that
you know is
helps the bottom say you know 10 10
or you know are you having gifted and
talented
um programs that help the the top 10 and
that's
so interesting because
people are very happy to talk about
things like um grammar schools you know
in britain and i guess the versions of
those in the us too about programs that
help
or the already lucky i guess succeed
even further but it's not consider you
know we don't we don't have the
conversation about how whether or not
that's happening at the expense of
people who are you know you could move
up from being terrible students to be
mean slightly below average or average
students that's not seen as being such
an exciting
you know sexy conversation to have i
guess
yeah i mean
the example that i'm talking about there
is you know when we look at many of the
programs that we try in education
there's kind of two problems
about them and this is true in both the
u.s context and a uk context which is
that most of the things we try in
education
don't work they don't make a difference
on average for students
um if they do work those effects fade
out often or are very difficult to scale
or replicate
and then even among the things that do
work
even when they raise the average they
often also exacerbate the very
inequalities that people talk about
as their locus of concern a classic
example in a u.s context is sesame
street so sesame street is you know big
bird is on the tv and is talking about
you know the word of the day or the
letter of the day and there's the count
that introduces numbers and the reason
why we have this on public access
television in the us is that it was an
effort
to expose more low-income children to
literacy and numeracy even before they
started school because low-income
children start kindergarten already
behind high-income children in terms of
their early school readiness skills
so sesame street works in the sense that
children who watch sesame street read
earlier they read better it you know
schooling works if you teach
four-year-olds their letters and numbers
they learn them
it doesn't do what it was originally
designed to do it was just to close
income gaps because even though it helps
low income children it helps middle and
high income children more so this is
what a lot of people call a matthew
effect where the rich get richer the
most most advanced you know to whom
already has gets even more
this is a pervasive problem in education
um
it's
it's a problem that we can turn a blind
eye to if we're ignoring genetic
heterogeneity between students because
we know that there's these gaps between
kids and how well they're going to do
some part of that is based on their
genotype
but most educators most policymakers
most educational interventionists are
not including genetic information at all
in their studies so who are
interventions surveying are they all
having these kind of matthew effects
where they're changing the mean but
exacerbating inequality the short answer
is we don't really have a good answer to
that question
and that lack of information allows
people this is circling back to
answering your question
allows people to
not be transparent about
what are your goals what are your values
in terms of designing this educational
system people can have very different
goals about whether or not it's more
important for them to maximize
performance amongst a very few versus
raise the floor to a certain level
um but often people don't even have to
commit to like well what is their vision
of what this educational intervention or
what this educational policy will do for
inequality who is it intending to serve
um we act as if things that work work
for everyone and work for everyone the
same way
and that's just not empirically true so
this is an example in which the
you know neglecting the science allows
people
to kind of sweep under the rug some
things that i i think would be important
policy conversations about you know what
what are people's values in terms of who
they want to serve the most at different
points in their educational trajectory
that was one of the things i came across
really strongly and actually it made me
think about the fact that
the underpinning of a lot of um
right-wing arguments in economic terms
is about the idea that someone some
level of inequality is good you know
it's a spur to other people to do
more you know that you want to have
things other people have that you don't
and and i thought that's really
interesting i actually haven't heard
that vocalized it doesn't come up much
now because every like equality is seen
as
such a buzz word and such an achievement
in public policy but you can go back to
rules in the book and saying that
sometimes we might tolerate inequalities
if they raise the level for everybody
right it's all good for us to live in a
society where the occasional person gets
to be a neurosurgeon or gets to you know
be a superstar inventor because we all
benefit from that and and yeah i i
really like that it forced me into
confrontation with saying what what you
know what are you prepared to tolerate
for the for the good of everybody what
level of inequality is is right and it's
it's a very fundamental policy question
that weirdly gets dodged a lot these
days i think
i think it does get dodged or
or it gets shunted into a quality of
education and even that is kind of a
dodge because what level of education
are we talking about for whom
in the us and i think this is also the
case in the uk there's a lot of emphasis
on
um
getting more people to university or
equalizing university participation
across groups
which i think is a good thing i mean i
think university education for many
people is good in and of itself
but i too often i think that
conversation distracts from
are we actually trying to equalize
university participation
or are we trying to equalize
access to jobs that are secure and
well-paying are we trying to
equalize the sorts of neighborhoods that
people live in in terms of their freedom
from environmental toxins and level of
um you know order and green space
do we actually care about everyone
having an equal likelihood of having a
stem bachelor's degree or is it just
that we've
we've piled up so many other things on
top of being universe educated in terms
of access to a life without precarity in
terms of access to power and those are
the things we're actually interested in
equalizing not everyone's mathematics
ability at a certain level um so all of
that to say i agree with you in that we
can't have a conversation about just
equality i think we have to be very
specific about a quality of what and are
we interested in equality as a means to
another end or as an end to itself and i
think those conversations are often
alighted in many of our conversations
about education
yeah i think the book has landed at a
really interesting time you know around
these conversations you reference
freddie deboer in there whose book cult
of smart makes some similar arguments
about the fact that we have you know
we've built up this idea where education
is the be all and end all and and
actually is that necessarily the correct
way to structure a society as you say
the other way of looking at it is why
have wages stagnated for people without
a college degree for for 20 years and
what kind of life can you build for
yourself if you don't have higher
education and and the idea that well
actually we'll just make more people go
into higher education is a kind of dodge
out of that
the other moment that the book hits
really well um you were obviously
writing this and prepping it for
publication and
during last summer's protest black lives
matter's protest over the um death of
george floyd
and you're also
another book that this is in the shadow
of another intellectual traditionist in
the shadow is um
the book that charles murray co-authored
the bell curve can you explain
uh to the casual listener why that is
such a
controversial book in this field and why
because you explicitly repudiate it very
early on in your book and you obviously
felt that you had to do that in order to
get the ability to talk on the subject
so why does that loom so large over this
conversation
i mean the bell curve sold i think like
400 000 copies which is an absolutely
bananas number for
a 900 page book that's mostly analyses
of data from the you know the nlsy which
is the data set in the us
and it had several key arguments that
there were genetic differences between
people that influenced the development
of traits such as intelligence
that intelligence test scores predicted
um something about class structure in
american life occupational outcomes
participation in the labor market more
generally income and the acquisition of
wealth
and those parts of the bell curve are
very similar to the evidence that i
present in my book
what was controversial about the bell
curve and and the parts that i disagree
with are points three and four and so
which was that
um the differences between racial groups
uh particularly between whites and
blacks in america could best described
in terms of genetics um at least
partially in terms of genetics
and that the social inequalities that
result from genetics are immutable or
inexorable unable to be addressed
through social policy that you know that
some sort of version of the poor will
always be with us because of their genes
that's the kind of ultimate conclusion
of the bell curve
whereas my book describes two things
that i think are really important and
one is
that race is not a genetic concept and
that we don't really have any evidence
that
the sort of genetic differences that we
observe within
people who are homogeneously of european
genetic ancestry
explain these kind of racialized health
and education disparities that we see
across groups
um and two
yeah i i
um talk about why
genetically cause differences can
absolutely be ameliorated or addressed
using environments using social policies
um the classic example here which was
presented in the 1970s is
eyeglasses right your genes might have
caused you to have poor eyesight but we
are not crisper in your genes we are
putting on an environmental
um intervention and there's several
examples in my book of
um you know genes that cause something
about an individual's you know
interaction with their environment and
it's that an environment that we can
intervene on to change that genetic
relationship
so i think it's really important given
how
large the bell curve learnt loomed in
the american imagination in particular
the strong claims that need around
racialized genetic differences um i felt
in order for us to have a conversation
about what the science does say i need
to be really clear up front about where
my points of disagreement were because
if to the extent that people have have
thought about this topic before very
often their exposure is um murray and
herzegs the bell curve
i was very surprised i mean actually not
when i thought about it but um
you point out that the vast majority of
um
genetic research has been done on people
of european ancestry so we just don't
have particularly good mapping for
people of other other heritages which i
thought was interesting and then to go
back to um galton in either hereditary
genius or one of his other books he
talks about racialized differences in
intelligence and he has this idea that
the classical greeks were two standard
deviations above modern caucasians and
he was like where are you getting this
from um
and the same thing comes up that you
mentioned in in the book that the idea
of what white was in the middle 20th
century in america is specifically
excluding for example italians and
polish people right so these the racial
categories are incredibly slippy even
within recent memory
is there any like is there any is all of
this subject simply are they too toxic
or too little to pseudoscience or are
there interesting things to say about
race and iq or is just the whole subject
just should be walled off with a kind of
radiation sheet like chernobyl
i mean i think the most interesting
conversation about race and iq that i
have heard recently is by
um
uh harriet washington who wrote a
terrible thing to waste
she is a scholar of color
who has pushed back against kind of an
american tradition of rejecting iq tests
that's valuable
and is saying they are valuable they're
valuable because they are sensitive to
neurobiological insult
and to the toxicity that we see from say
exposure to lead
and she's suggesting
you know we can look at iq tests and use
them as a really valuable tool for
documenting the effects of environmental
racism that children of color
in the us are much more exposed to
things we know are harmful for the
development of intelligence such as lead
in
pipes and in houses and in soil of
formerly industrialized areas um
that is the part of the race iq
conversation where there's interesting
science and there's more light than heat
right whereas i think the kind of mur
hernstein murray let's speculate wildly
in the absence of evidence about you
know genetic differences between
socially constructed racial groups um i
just find really dissatisfactory from a
scientific perspective
even just the idea of talking about
black people in the us as this
monolithic
entity
you know when we look at when we look at
african ancestry groups
there's such incredible genetic
diversity there two people from africa
can be as genetically different from
each other
as you are from someone from east asia
and we collapse all the genetic
diversity into
this label that we've given to the
descendants of slaves and i just think
calling enslaved people black and then
treating that as a genetically
homogeneous group it's it's
scientifically ridiculous and it doesn't
advance the science it doesn't advance
either the conversation or the science
in any real meaningful way
but in what ways is
iq useful to talk about just as a
concept because it did go through quite
a backlash you know steven j gold's
mismeasure of man and then there was a
lot of work about you know do iq tests
just measure how good you are at iq test
so and then the really the term and
research you know lewis determines
research about in very high iq children
which didn't show that they were all
like mini geniuses i think quite
famously like the only one who won a
nobel prize like was had their iq was
slightly too low to be in one of his
termites yeah but there are yeah to your
mind there are bits of iq that are worth
rehabilitating like it's a useful index
on on what kind of measures
yeah
so there's really two very common
extreme views on iq and they're both
wrong so one extreme view is that
there's nothing to it
that iq just measures how good you are
iq tests
that it um has no purpose other than
sort of
entrenching racist or classes bias
um
and that's not true because we can see
that performance on intelligence test
scores
um predicts things that we care about in
life and it's um you know i think the
one of the most compelling research
studies on this um was done in scotland
the lothian birth cohort study
um where
you know following up on scottish school
children who were all tested on their
acute age 11
and you see that those age 11 test
scores predict things like how long
people live even above measures of their
early social class
so
you know what is what is intelligence
what is g
is you know i think a topic that will be
endlessly fascinating to psychologists
and you know philosophers of the mind
whatever it's getting at it's getting at
a suite of abilities that are broadly
useful in
educational systems and high-income
countries in labor markets and
in you know navigating an environment
such that you
have access to more sort of health
promoting services and the mechanisms of
that are unclear but i think the the
predictive value of iq tests
um is pretty incontrovertible at the
same time it's not the end-all be-all of
of human skill right so the other
extreme view is to talk about
intelligence or g or iq
as well just to gloss that for people is
general intelligence right that's sure
general intelligence yes yeah
yes
um that that you know some people talk
about that as if it's like
talent
writ large or skill writ large that it
is a marker of all the
you know useful things that humans can
do with their body or brain and that's
also obviously not true i mean i think
there's been increasingly
push back even against the language and
economics you know often economists talk
about skilled versus unskilled labor
skilled being labor that requires a
college degree
but if you look at unskilled labor
whether that's being a plumber or being
a waitress
or being a farmworker
those are skills those are skills that
are valuable um they're just not skills
that are necessarily implicated at
university
um
they often require a lot of training and
expertise so i think we can think of it
as both more useful but more limited
than than its advocates or its critics
often
and portrayed as it is a really reliable
measure of one domain of human cognitive
functioning that's predictive of lots of
things given the outsized role that
formal education plays
in modern american and british society
but it is not
um
intelligence or reason capital r as the
kind of the end-all be-all of of um of
human reasoning or human talent
i also think the problem with some of
that skill discussion is there's a kind
of tyranny of metrics about it right
like if you're a quant or uh you know
you're working in some financial domain
it's quite easy to tell whether you're
good at it or not right there is lots of
data to supply performance data if
you're exact like a home carer we can
obviously say that some people are much
better at that but it's much more
nebulous to say
you see problems before they come or you
make people feel better about themselves
or you're really warm like that's
there's no easy you know data led
approach to some of that stuff and i
think that that strikes me quite
strongly i want to go back to the
loathing cohort because you mentioned
age 11 and that's a very kind of totemic
number in the uk because we used to have
the 11 plus which was what decided
whether or not you went to grammar
school you were considered you know a
bright kid who was headed for higher
education or whether or not you went to
a technical college
very controversial there's still some
grammar schools left but um
but you also write in the book about
this idea of polygenic scores so the
idea that you can't there's no one gene
for intelligence but they're a kind of
suite of genes that you can look at and
kind of come up with a profile
and i wonder when i was i've read about
the 11 plus about children who failed it
and the fact that they then felt that
was it they were on the scrap people at
11.
is it a good idea to know your polygenic
score
oh that's so interesting
i think like every piece of information
about yourself is going to have pros and
cons um i think
the con of it would be if you
misunderstand it as destiny
is something that's insurmountable
or something that's stigmatizing
um
at the same time people like knowing
about themselves there's a reason why
ancestry.com and 23. you know 23andme
are multi-million dollar businesses
um you can get genetic information about
your likelihood of liking cilantro and
like being bald as a baby
um
so i think there's always going to be
that
um push-pull between
uh
people like to know about themselves
tell me quickly about um
cilantro which is
coriander in the uk there is some kind
of genetic association thinking it
tastes like soap is that right or
something like that yes it is it's
actually um a gene that's associated and
i think this is less polygenic i think
this is actually maybe monogenic which
is rare for almost anything we're going
to talk about intelligence or
schizophrenia
height
all influenced by thousands upon
thousands of genes each with small
effect but i'm pretty sure cilantro is a
one gene of
a relatively large effect and it affects
how you how you taste it so for some
people it tastes like soap and they you
know they spit it out um they pick it
off their tacos uh
whereas other people it's just you know
i love it can't get enough of it i'm in
that i'm in the last account i
definitely know what version of that
jean i've got um it's time for me just
to go to some questions so people um are
watching this can still ask them uh
you're very welcome to put them in the
chat um
this question comes in from uh i cannot
see the name but i will tell you that
anyway how can a better understanding of
genetic inheritance improve oh stella
how can a better understanding of
genetic inheritance improve the
education system so if you accept your
premise what is the policy outcome from
that i guess
yeah
so
this is a little bit counter-intuitive
but the best way for genetics to improve
policy is actually by improving the
research on which policy is based so if
we think about what we're trying in
education let's try this new curriculum
let's teach teach teachers about
mindsets let's try to retroactively sort
of like reverse engineer the
characteristics of successful teachers
successful schools successful school
districts successful parents success in
this in this way i'm saying
features of people that are correlated
with children doing well in school
that research
is easier to do
if we have good controls for the fact
that children are genetically different
from one another the central problem of
most of social science is that kids
don't end up in their environments at
random and so
is it something that mom is doing that's
making the child better at you know
reading when they start school or is it
those two things are correlated but it's
not that mom's actually doing it it's
just that's the behavior of moms that's
influenced by her temperament and the
child is is inheriting the genes
that problem of being unable to control
for genetic differences is absolutely
rampant in all of developmental
psychology educational psychology
sociology
and so we are often very often trying
interventions and policies
on the basis of
a bad model of what's causing what in
child development
and then most of things those things
don't work which has a huge opportunity
cost and an actual cost like educational
interventions are expensive
so a lot of times when people hear about
genetic research linking education their
minds jump to
you know a teacher is going to do some
sort of personalizing in the classroom
like little tommy has this genetic score
so he's going to get this reading
material that is not my suggestion at
all my suggestion is that if we want to
change the world we need to understand
it better and researchers who take into
account genetic differences between kids
have a better chance of understanding
the world of human development of child
development better that's the that is
the entry floor for genetics and that's
where we should be starting
it's a very depressing conclusion the
idea that most interventions don't don't
work but i guess it's better than not
knowing that and spending lots more
money on them um i have a question from
emma uh who says if we have to take into
account the role of genetic luck that
famous sum over the others in terms of
equality what are your thoughts on
providing equal opportunities to even
things out rather than equal ones
so i think this is one of the most um
this is the bit in the book that i think
will probably have right-wing people
having some palpitations because
you quote freddie the board talking
about equality of opportunity being kind
of a big lie really so there's a whole
debate about the difference between the
quality of outcome the idea of sort of
flattening things out plus the quality
of opportunity and basically everybody
seems to be on board with the quality of
opportunity like giving everyone a fair
shake
but if you're coming from this
incredibly disadvantaged place in terms
as we've talked about both maybe in
intelligence and in terms of
conscientiousness risk-taking whatever
it is
you can't
that equality of opportunity is never
going to be equal so that's quite a
radical thing to accept and then devise
policy solutions on the basis of right
it is and it isn't it is radical because
i think that we
and you're absolutely right in an
american context there's a lot of
support for the idea of equality of
opportunity we're going to treat
everyone exactly the same everyone's
exactly equal under the law
um
but less support for worrying about
inequalities of outcome
and
in a world in which people are different
teaching treating everyone exactly the
same will necessarily reproduce those
differences
um it's not radical in one respect which
is that there are occasions in which we
already do it
a piece of legislation that i can find
continually fascinating is the americans
with disabilities act which was passed
passed by the first bush in 1990
and it is our anti-discrimination act
that requires buildings for instance to
accommodate people with disabilities
right so you can't just have a staircase
you have to have a wheelchair ramp um
that is an example in which
the law explicitly says
treating everyone exactly the same is
not enough to ensure a quality of
participation you cannot say i have a
business and everyone can use the same
stairs
because
people are different and they're
ambulatory functioning and that exact
sameness just reproduces differences in
their access what you have to equalize
is their and the
the wording of the law so interesting
here
their enjoyment of an accommodation by
that piece of business and that's a
really interesting to think it thing to
think about equalizing we're not
equalizing
the exact conditions and the thing well
everyone has the exact same treatment
and that's enough we can wash our hands
of worrying about justice
but we're also not concerned with
exactly equalizing
psychological or physical functioning or
even resources what we're equalizing is
um being in relationships of dignity
with one another no one needs to be
carried around the building
um the ability to participate in the
economy um the ability to participate in
public life
um that is the sort of equity that is
often lost in our conversations about
equality
so i again i'm less interested in
equalizing
everyone's likelihood of getting a phd
in clinical psychology which is what my
degree is
i'm interested in a society in which
there aren't strong bottlenecks
to
the sort of lives that we feel like are
reflective of human dignity and people
can get through through lots of
different ways what are the social
wheelchair ramps to to add to our stairs
that we have here
and we already do that in the realm of
physical difference in some cases
but we're less able i think to imagine
our social structures doing that that
sort of thing around psychological
difference
um
so that's the kind of more more radical
reimagining i'm suggesting in this book
which is probably a good time to ask you
whether or not you've had more uh
backlash to this book from the left or
the right because there's something in
there for
something for everyone to disagree with
there's so much
for everyone yes
which i think you know in some ways on a
good day i think it's a good thing right
i wrote the book in part to get a
conversation started and i did i think
successfully do that to the extent that
people are responding to it and thinking
about um you know which parts they agree
with and disagree with
um
it's been really interesting because i
feel like in on social media it's been
probably equal parts far left and far
right um with you know some people on
the far left are really committed to the
idea that linking human difference to
genetics is bad full stop you know even
if you can identify some instrumentally
good uses for it
and some people on the far right that
are just
um you know anything that is like
devoted towards equality per se is
bad
you know full stop
um what i've been really struck by is
the disconnects between the kind of
social media chatter and people's
um
uh
reaching out to me privately so the
email versus the email response or the
letter response versus twitter because
my emails have been lovely actually they
have been
people saying you've made me think
differently about my own children you've
made me think differently about my own
siblings you've made me think
differently about my own students
or how can i help right like i
am in this foundation or i'm developing
this data resource or i'm in this public
policy institute
um i think this is important how can we
connect it and those responses for me
outweigh any of the kind of social media
chatter
around it and because i think it's a
sign that there's there's more serious
engagement with the idea
there's a very funny line in the profile
of you in the new yorker about i think
it was after you went on sam harris's
podcast about you being submitted to
levels of podcasting that were by any
standards extreme
sustained levels of podcasting
yes yes and i thought they were so
interesting but and i was very pleased
to hear that you would you had been on
sam harris's podcast because i do think
there is an issue but and it came up in
lots of discussions we had a couple of
years ago about the so-called
intellectual dark web that if um people
who self-identify as progressives as you
do don't engage with these oh no one
wants to talk about this subject you
know that they don't want you to know
about this you know this is some
unspoken truth that the msm don't want
you to hear that is a very very powerful
message and one that people find
incredibly appealing the idea that the
thing is we all know there are racial
differences but you're not allowed to
say that right and it needs someone to
go in and say well actually here's the
evidence on it i'm not going to say
this you're being offensive i'm going to
say you're wrong and that's something i
think that the left is kind of whiffed a
little bit recently
i agree with that i think so often
people say
to me you know what are the risks of
talking about this this being genetics
and i always say it is it is not as if
you know clinical psychologists doing
genetics are over here like turning the
crank of the conversation about genetics
in
in people's lives like this is a topic
that
people are talking about that they if
you ask
just lay people do genetics make an
influence on you know your life or your
children's life they say yes
so if if
psychologists and geneticists and
sociologists who spend our lives
thinking about human difference
are not engaging
that doesn't make the conversation go
away it just creates this oh it's
forbidden knowledge
um kind of uh aura around it and i agree
with you that i think that's a very
dangerous place for it to be
as someone who used to edit a news
website let me tell you that nothing is
more clickable than like
they people don't want you to know this
but like you know any idea that this is
sort of like you're you're being
inducted into some kind of mysterious
hush-hush thing that people don't want
you to know is yeah even when you're
taking the red pill or the blue or
whatever which whatever it is yeah
and i so i think i think it's i think
it's it's wishful thinking to think if
you never talk about genetics then race
realists or whatever they want to call
themselves now we'll kind of just go
away and stop talking about this i have
one that's very left field here in the
questions for you to what extent does
gut microbiome nullify inherited
genetics
i mean i love the
biome yeah
i don't think i so i don't think
anything in turn i don't tend to think
of levels of information as nullifying
each other right so the microbiome is
part of the larger set of omics right we
can think about the genome we can think
about the biome we can think about the
epigenome we can think about
um the environmental layers of
environmental
context in which people are
and
i am a multi-level multi-layer thinker
and i am because i think human
development is multi-layer multi-level
so we
generally i don't think we should be
thinking about
how does one thing nullify each other
but what can we learn from combining
those sources of information um
so for instance you know if you're i
think a really great example of the
power of the gut biome is if you're
looking at children with
um
autism they also have severe epilepsy as
a comorbid condition and one of the um
treatments for epilepsy is a very
particular diet so you're changing what
you're putting into your gut and that's
changing your your vulnerability to
seizure activity so obviously like you
know our genes don't stop at the neck in
either direction and what's happening in
one part of our body can be affected by
another part of our body
um in my lab we study
um not the gut microbiome but we do
study things like food security and
insecurity so to what extent does that
variability and access to um nutritious
um
fresh food
relate to
patterns of early puberty or
[Music]
dna methylation patterns that are
related to aging um so we're always
looking for how can we integrate another
level of information about what's going
on particularly when we're talking about
child development
which is related to another question
that's come up in the chat which is a
how does epigenetics
filter into your work
yeah so epigenetics is an interesting
word it's a little bit like eugenics and
that it has a lot of different meanings
for different people so give me a give
me a concise yeah am i right in thinking
this is about how uh environment alters
the expression of genes is that a way of
one way of conceptualizing it
yes which and it's absolutely necessary
so like every cell in your body has the
same genome but your liver cells don't
look or act like your brain cells and
why is that because of epigenetic
genetics there are
dynamic
tissue specific developmental
environmentally responsive changes to
gene expression that are happening
all of the time
my work tends to look at um one
epigenetic signature which is called dna
methylation so methyl groups can bond to
parts of the genome and that affect its
ability to be read and expressed in a
certain tissue
and we're interested in dna methylation
because it is correlated with social
inequalities so in austin children
growing up in poverty
show dna methylation signatures that in
adults are associated with earlier
mortality and faster biological aging
um
a lot of times people are interested
when people ask me that question they're
particularly interested in epigenetic
inheritance which is something about the
way that my genome is expressed
as influenced by my environment
are those epigenetic signatures passed
on to offspring
that's a very controversial field
particularly in humans and i don't
personally do anything related to
epigenetic inheritance i'm really
looking about over the course of
someone's own life
how does their environmental exposures
um relate to these signatures of how
genes might be being turned on or turned
off
in certain tissues at certain points in
their life
you can answer that a bit in the book by
quoting this um research which suggests
that perhaps uh you know all these
anti-smoking measures have made it
easier for people who's who don't have
the genetic markers that make you more
prone to addiction right so
all the people who find it easy to quit
smoking have quit smoking yeah and so
we're now penalizing harder the people
who who can't which i think is such a
fascinating i remember when um i was at
new states when we had richard dawkins
guest editing and he was saying that he
had taken uh a test and he found that he
got the markers for if you had ever
tried smoking you would have found it
incredibly addictive and like it just so
happened that he'd never
you know tried a cigarette and and that
seems to me to be part of the
interesting message of your book but
instead of this very old-school eugenics
determinist idea that you know you just
you're a slave to your genes that there
is some measure we could use this
knowledge to help us be more
understanding that other people find
things harder than we do right like oh i
find it so easy to quit smoking or you
know thin people are like well i've
never had a problem losing weight or
whatever it might be or um you know in
the same way that uh you know
that people might be more prone to
violent outbursts and and rage and if
you've never felt that you just can't
understand what that experience is is
like there is a kind of somewhere there
a plea that people are kind of
you know having they're living their
lives in a fundamentally different
body than you are in a brain experience
than you are and that could make you
more empathetic to them right
yeah i mean i think if we look at the
history of many social movements in the
u.s around
reducing stigma around mental illness or
this has been quite prominent in gay
rights emphasizing
that a biological component to a
behavior or to a disposition has been a
really important part of demoralizing it
to making it a more morally neutral
aspect of human difference rather than a
thing to be
um
uh
you know evaluated as good or bad qua in
this in some sort of moral or ethical
sense so i think there's that's one
interesting layer of it
i think another interesting layer of it
is exactly what you just said which is
in contrast to this kind of
deterministic perspective on genes
we can look at examples in which
people might have been at genetic risk
for addiction but now we tax cigarettes
immensely and they smoke less right
that's not a
um
again we're not crispering their genes
we're not selecting embryos we're
changing tax policy but in so doing
we're changing the relationship between
someone's genetic vulnerabilities and
their outcomes
and then also i think it speaks to you
know all as as this research progresses
i see in the book in the last chapter i
give these kind of principles for
anti-eugenic practice and policy and one
of them is can we think about genetics
as a tool not for classifying people but
for understanding environments
and the tobacco the tobacco tax one is a
great one which is
we can see who has been helped by a
policy regime
and who has been left behind what's
different about the people who have been
left behind
what do we need to try differently for
people who aren't responding to the
incentives of taxation in the way that
most of the population does
so it's not about abandoning anyone to
their fate it's about identifying
what's working for whom
who's not being served what do we need
to try for them um
again it's around having this kind of
pluralistic opportunities to success
rather than forcing everyone through the
same bottleneck
just before i hand back over to connor i
want to ask you one final question which
is apart from buying your book which is
both um
very
very challenging and provocative and
written for the lay read your mind like
there are bits about chicken in it that
you in in the film parasites that
in in mostly quite hardcore genetics um
what should what is there one thing that
people should go away and read or do
following on from the lessons you've
learned from writing this
you know there's um
there is uh an essay that i wrote for
eon earlier this year
that's about it's called
what do we do with the science of
terrible men and it's a play on emily uh
nussbaum's column on what do we do with
the art of terrible men
and it's struggling with
we know that genetics has this eugenic
legacy we know that statistics has a
pseudogenic legacy
how can we reclaim those tools for more
positive ends while still recognizing
the deep moral limitations and
ideological limitations of the inventors
of these tools so if you're not ready to
commit to buying the book you can just
google page harden what do we do with
the science of terrible men
and i think it's a good introduction to
many of these issues
that is a great recommendation thank you
very much